[Musica]
buonasera le extensions sono le stazioni
del pianeta terra e sono l'ufficio di
domani l'ufficio del futuro
quando hai cominciato a disegnare uffici
per la olivetti nel 1978 le cose erano
molto diverse si destinino gli uffici
mettendo le scrivanie una dopo l'altra
realizzando file infinite li scrive
e dopo alla fine se c'era spazio nel
pianerottolo della scala si metteva la
macchinetta del caffè adesso è che
andato completamente tutto si incomincia
a disegnare dalla dalla macchinetta del
caffè che non è più una macchinetta del
caffè ma è proprio una caffetteria o
addirittura un ristorante e e dopo si
disegna l'ufficio tutto attorno è
cambiato tutto sta cambiando tutto ma
dico quella di più quello che sta
cambiando adesso cambierà ancora
tra poco tra molto poco tempo e e mini
accordo nel lavoro che faccio che molto
spesso costruisco dei grandi edifici che
quando sono finiti meriterebbero essere
ricominciati da casa
e allora mi sono detto qui gli
architetti devono incominciare a pensare
loro al futuro e pensare loro è il
cambiamento perché se non sono gli
architetti che pensano al cambiamento
tutti i cambiamenti futuri di dovremmo
subire e non li poteva invece godere
come come meritano essere goduti che ci
sono tutti i cambiamenti che ci portano
ad una condizione migliore
al world economic forum di davos che
ogni anno in gennaio all'inizio
dell'anno di una stazione sciistica in
mezzo alle montagne è stato un po si
riuniscono tutti i più grandi direttori
e presidenti delle aziende delle banche
delle istituzioni anche i presidenti
delle repubbliche o oi presidenti delle
monarchie si chiamano re ma va bene lo
stesso essi lunghissima per parlare di
economia dello stato dell'economia e del
futuro
quest'anno hanno fatto una sessione
speciale dedicata al mondo dell'ufficio
e insieme hanno ragionato su come possa
essere l'ufficio del futuro sono venuti
fuori delle cose incredibili
proprio una lista di temi da da tenere
in considerazione delle quali la prima
dice cose bisogna vendere la gente le
persone si lavora negli uffici
confortevoli con il cambiamento
confortevoli con il cambiamento vogliono
essere sempre disposti a cambiare e
sempre pronti a cambiare fa rinunciando
a tutto quello che magari anche
comodamente cerchiamo di trascinare più
avanti più a lungo possibile perché non
si può non vivere senza il cambiamento
poi non ha detto anche altre cose hanno
detto che per esempio bisognerà che gli
uffici del futuro siano sempre più fra
riferiti agli uomini e meno riferite
alle macchine
mi sono anche giunto poi hanno detto
bisogna togliere tutte le gerarchie
perché nelle gerarchie non si riesce a
utilizzare quelle connessioni che fanno
grande il genere umano
sapete che il genere umano può essere
paragonato un cervello ci sono
destinarsi ci sono i collegamenti e il
cervello umano che probabilmente il
cervello che ho voluto tra tutte
gli animali e tutti gli altri generi che
esistono sei messo in rete funziona come
un cervello gigantesco con una potenza
straordinaria tutta ancora da scoprire
il grande tema è proprio togliere le
gerarchie per mettere insieme i cervelli
per metter insieme le persone è l'ultima
cosa che è che dicono è che anche questa
mi sembra meritevole di essere ricordate
bisogna pensare in grande e bisogna
mettere le persone nelle condizioni di
pensare in grande perché pensare in
piccolo non porta niente porta a dei
risultati che nelle condizioni in cui
siamo nelle condizioni per le quali
siamo 8 miliardi di persone nove
miliardi di persone a breve i 10
miliardi di persone sul pianeta
non possiamo più permetterci lei ha
spesso le stazioni del pianeta terra
sono proprio dei luoghi che servono per
mettere insieme la gente è sbagliato
oggi proprio pensare di disegnare e
immaginare degli uffici con delle
separazioni tra una persona all'altra da
un gruppetto non c'è un piano e l'altro
gli uffici devono proprio essere dei
luoghi dove ci si incontri dove si ha
piacere ad andare e chi se non si ha
piacere oggi che si è scoperto che si
può lavorare ovunque negli uffici non
andrà più nessuno e infatti questa è
stata una preoccupazione espressa dai
signori di da bossi come fare per far sì
che le persone parlano in ufficio e
volentieri con uno stimolo psicologico
per stare insieme e per lavorare insieme
per creare insieme avrebbe potuto
chiamare questo progetto che ne son gli
uffici della della pista
le cattedrali del mondo del lavoro e o
chiamate a se stesso perché sono delle
stazioni cioè sono dei luoghi dove si va
per partire non sono delle destinazioni
questi dello stesso si fa perché si
vuole con la mente con le emozioni con
l'istinto andare avanti dare un
contributo all'evoluzione del mondo cosa
sono queste queste stations sono sono
dei grandi padiglioni delle grandi
manifestazioni appunto senza piani tutte
ad un piano unico che raccolgono in un
idea architettonica il massimo di
entusiasmo e di immaginazione per questo
futuro migliore che tutti ci aspettiamo
sono sistemati i luoghi diversissimi
l'avete visto questa è sistemata proprio
in una prateria di un luogo abbandonato
che ti presento a nord del kazakhstan
dove non c'è niente dove non c'è nessuno
e dove mi chiedono di fare dei progetti
perché la gente possa andare lì e possa
dire voglio andare a lui dove c'è quella
cosa lì sono dei posti proprio alle 3
all'estremo delle condizioni climatiche
si raggiungono i 50 gradi sopra zero
d'estate i 50 gradi sotto zero d'inverno
per però sono dei posti bellissimi sono
posti della terra che noi delle
architetture con degli edifici con delle
con delle regioni oggi possiamo andare e
possiamo usare il vivere e godere di
tutta quella bellezza che cerete la moto
station è l'evoluzione delle stazioni
televisive delle degli studi televisivi
di tutti quei luoghi dove si si
trasmette è infatti tutte le station
sono connesse tra di loro
e l'idea di andare a lavorare e
comunicare per trasmettere qualcosa così
come facciamo oggi
adesso è come fate da da tanti anni
e proprio la ragione più straordinarie
di uno può trovare per sfruttare bene il
proprio tempo la propria giornata la
propria capacità di fare outing stesso
invece sono proprio delle sale di
convesso delle banali se volete sale di
congresso di ispirazione viene proprio
da da bossi in mezzo in mezzo alle alpi
svizzere dove ci si riunisce per le
riunioni al vertice
ed è proprio in cima alla montagna in un
luogo bellissimo ma in un luogo che
bisogna a dell'intenzione di raggiungere
perché raggiungere questa condizione di
pensare in grande è un obiettivo non è
solamente una cosa che si fa solamente
per per piacere per dibattimento si ci
si arriva con la con le funivie si
sollevano con gli elicotteri ci si
arriva a piedi sono dei posti dove ci si
arriva proprio per mettere la propria
mente nello stato psicologico per
pensare nella maniera più ottimistica e
più positiva al futuro il questa zattera
in un file che porto che non so se del
lontano oriente ed odio dell'est
dell'america dell'europa è una zattera
che è praticamente un centro fieristico
un distretto fieristico dove si fanno le
fiere e dove ognuno può andare a tele
esporre i propri prodotti
proprio i propri processi ma anche le
proprie idee e questa è la fiera delle
idee la fiera delle idee dove nella
massima flessibilità e adattabilità
possibile ciascuno potrà non solamente
comunicare le provvide a ricevere le
idee degli altri perché è proprio in
questa combinazione continua di
conoscenze di stimoli risi pc che si può
ottenere la condizione migliore per le
grandi idee
la cao station invece è una biblioteca
una normale biblioteca normale normale
perché ci sono i libri di carta ma
normale anche perché ci sono i libri
digitali e dove si combina insieme
proprio tutte le conoscenze immaginatevi
una biblioteca di alessandria portata
oggi è rinnovata in tutte le sue
potenzialità in tutte le sue
combinazioni è fatta è fatta è appesa è
appreso perché la cultura è un ponte ed
è circolare perché la conoscenza come
già il filosofo invece il peri patente
se avevano capito la società e
camminando da solo tiene mettendo un
passo davanti al lancio proprio anche
con il coraggio di lanciarsi avanti
perché sapete che ogni passo che si fa
camminando e proprio non sbilanciarsi in
avanti un cardine dell'equilibrio per
poi riconquistarlo nel mediatamente
l'ucid stesso invece sono dei laboratori
dei laboratori di artigiani che lavorano
con la pelle con il cuoio con le carte i
tessuti in legno ma sono anche dei
laboratori di più alta tecnologia
disponibile dove si possono farlo
mettere insieme il saper artigianale
come sapere tecnologico e mettendo
insieme questo che ci potrà ci si possa
arrivare ad un futuro più vicino
all'uomo dove l'uomo ha più libertà più
risorse e più tempo per essere creativo
tutti nel futuro dovremmo essere un po
più artisti di quelle che siamo oggi la
cloud stesso invece pensate un po è un
un centro commerciale
uno di quei centri commerciali che si
vedono nelle periferie delle grandi
città ma questo è un museo è una
galleria d'arte e il luogo della
creatività lo ha proprio sistemato così
perché volevo che forse un humus un
simbolo del mondo contemporaneo della
vita contemporanea però rilanciato
rilanciato verso questa quest'arte che
molto spesso il misterioso difficile da
capire ma che ci aiuta così tanto
ad aprire gli occhi ea vedere con degli
occhi diversi
tutto quello che magari proprio perché è
troppo vicino al nostro naso non
riusciamo più a vedere queste sono gli
uffici dove delle idee nascono e
crescono grazie
[Applauso]